♪♪
Will Ferrell:
Take two, Apple mark.
(Clap)
-Ok, we're good.
-We're good.
Do I say action?
(Crew laughing)
♪Christmas Morning Feelin'♪
I am the ghost of Christmas present.
You're going full Dickens on me?
Present:
Get ready.
There's something very special's about to happen.
Ohhh.
(Laughing)
Chorus:
♪Just begun♪
♪♪
Present:
(Laughing)
That's just fun to watch.
♪♪
Grab my hand.
Clint Briggs:
We're doing this?
Present:
We're doing it.
It's gonna be quite a ride.
Wahoo!
Ahh!
♪♪
Will Ferrell:
Sean gave me a call and said,
"We are thinking about doing a brand new version of Christmas Carol
Will Ferrell:
told from the perspective of the ghosts."
And then he said, "Oh, and it's a musical."
(Laughing)
All:
♪ Four, five, six♪
♪ One, two, three, four, good, hey ♪
I can tell you that Will, Ryan and I,
we all had a little panic feeling a little insecure about dancing.
(Laughing)
Ryan and I started talking, we're like, "We should really document how bad we are."
♪♪
(Laughing)
And hopefully there'll be some improvement.
♪♪
My wife made Will jelly tap shoes.
Ryan Reynolds:
That is spectacular.
The socks, bring the whole look together.
Making someone wear jelly tap shoes is assault, I think, in several states.
That's probably illegal.
But Will, of course, being Will, put them right on and went, did a little number.
In fact, roll the clip.
Chloe Arnold:
Five, six, seven, eight.
(Laughing)
Agh uh!
Chloe Arnold:
Don’t you hate it when...
Jelly taps!
Ryan Reynolds:
Nobody buys American anymore!
Gosh!
♪♪
Will Ferrell:
Between acting notes, dance notes, music notes,
your brain is like trying to play, you know, 3D chess and I'm only good for checkers.
♪Before it's all too late♪
(Beep)
♪Too late♪
♪Before it's all too late♪
(Beep)
Both:
(Laughing)
Full disclosure, we're not doing well.
Yep.
(Laughing)
Tiny thing, but any way that we can put that glottal on?
Ian would always come up with three quick things. Two quick things.
Cool?
Uh-huh!
I still don’t know what a glottal is.
Ryan Reynolds:
I would never ask what it meant, I would just agree, then I’d get a,
“You nailed it!"
"That was a lot of extra glottal!"
"Probably about 50% more."
"And that's sort of what I was looking for."
I'd be like, "Great".
"Great, I really glottal'd the [BLEEP] out of that."
♪I used to think that I was sure of what made people tick.♪
♪You strip them down right to their core and find a self-centered prick.♪
I feel very lucky to be a part of this. It’s so fun.
♪So can we do a little good♪
♪Do a little good♪
Chorus:
♪Give a little more♪
Ryan Reynolds:
Chorus:
♪Work a little...♪
For Ryan and I and Octavia to go through the dance and the singing, it’s just been such a joy.
♪Whether it's Christmas Day♪
Clint Briggs:
♪Or a random day in May.♪
Ryan Reynolds:
You can’t really put a price on having fun.
♪...What I want to say♪
Ryan Reynolds:
It’s just special and incredible.
Every second of it’s been pretty amazing.
Chorus
♪Do a little good.♪
Chorus:
♪Hey, just a little...♪
Clint:
♪Do a little good♪
Present:
Chours:
♪Just a little♪
Clint:
♪Do a little good♪
Chorus:
Haa!
Invigorating.
I’ve never done that before.
-Yeah, lot of fun!
-That was fun!